Okay, so welcome back to the screen, guys.
What we're actually going to do here now,
we're going to continue with the trade
idea generation process. But what we're
actually going to do here is marry up the
macro and the micro. So we're going to
take a slight detour from previous videos
because you can get trade ideas in many
different places. We're going to be
looking at generating trade ideas from
macroeconomic and macroeconomics.
indicators. So what does this involve?
Well, it's utilizing macro data that is
driving the performance of individual
stocks. So individual equities. So what
we're doing is we're getting trade ideas
in individual stocks that are driven by
macro data. So if you think way back to
the first part of the PTM video series,
when we were looking at
macroeconomic leading indicators, we were
using them primarily to obtain a portfolio
bias. But something else we can do, and it
was mentioned during that part of the PTM
video series, is we can actually use
leading indicators for trade idea
generation in individual equities. So what
we're going to do in this video is we're
going to bring the macro quantitative
quantitative and the micro quantitative
and the micro quantitative together as an
example of how you would regularly go
about processing this data to infer trends
and potential trade ideas from macro data
and micro data combined. Now what you're
going to see as we go through this video
is that the most important thing here is
to establish a link between the data from
the macroeconomic indicators and the
macroeconomic indicators and the
macroeconomic indicators and the forward
looking valuation data at the micro level.
So from the sector quantitative analysis.
So we'll get into all the details as we go
through the video. But our very first step
is always to establish a trend or a change
of trend in the macro data.
So we're attempting to marry this up with
the right stocks in the sector that are
displaying forward looking valuations and
growth profiles that are agreeing with the
macro data. So what we're going to do here
by way of an example. If you recall the
macroeconomic leading indicator dashboard,
we're not going to go through every single
macroeconomic indicator dashboard.
crow leading indicator that can provide
individual equities trade ideas. What
we're going to do is we're going to look
at the ISM manufacturing report on
business and all of the processes that we
go through utilizing the ISM manufacturing
numbers can be repeated with the ISM non
manufacturing report on business. So the
services sector.
Yes, you can get individual stock or
equities, you can get individual stock or
equities trade ideas from other surveys.
And what we're going to do actually in the
next video, we're going to look on the
right hand side of the macro leading
indicator dashboard. And we're going to be
looking at international trade ideas
generated by macro data. In addition, to
these two videos,
where we're looking at international
surveys, where we're looking at
international surveys, you can get trade
ideas in individual equities from other
leading indicators, like for example, the
Census Bureau's monthly report on building
permits. You can also get individual stock
trade ideas from cyclical commodities
prices. And you can also, for example,
look at corporate credit spreads. So
where you see, for example, where you see,
for example, credit conditions worsening
in certain sectors, or improving in
certain sectors, this can obviously feed
into the valuation of equities within
those sectors.
on the ISM manufacturing index on the ISM
manufacturing index. And the example we're
going to use is the sheet that's in the
downloads area. And this is going to be
for April 2021.
So everything we go through in this video
on the screen, you can look at the data in
the downloads area. And also, if you are
keeping the entire history of the ISM
manufacturing index and updating it every
month, you'll easily be able to navigate
to all of this data for that particular
month.
So let's take a look at this. So let's
begin looking at the ISM history. So let's
take a look at this. And let's begin
looking at the ISM history visually.
And we can see here that we've circled a
peak in the ISM manufacturing data in
recent history. And we can see here that
we've circled a peak in the ISM
manufacturing data in recent history. So
the data here is going back in this chart
to 1998. But we're looking at the most
recent peak, which was actually in March
2021.
So what we're looking at the US
manufacturing sector. So what we're
looking at here is obviously an inflection
point in the US manufacturing sector.
And if we look at this non pictorially, so
non visually on a chart, and we actually
look at the tables of data for the PMI and
all of its components.
You can see at the bottom here, so the
data is going back to July 2018, up till
April 21.
You can see at the bottom here, we've
highlighted in red, March 2021, and April
2021.
And you can see at the headline number,
the headline PMI, in March 2021, that was
the peak on our chart that we looked at.
That number is 64.7. And then there's a
slowdown. So quite a sharp slowdown of
four points to 60.7 in April 2021.
And if we look at the component data, so
first of all, we look at new orders, which
often leads the component index, we see a
slowdown from 68 to 64.3.
What we also see in terms of moves
contributing to the aggregate going down,
we see a slowdown in production.
We see a slowdown in employment
conditions. And also we see a draw in
inventories.
So imagine yourself doing this analysis,
sitting in the month of April.
So at the beginning of April, what would
have been happening?
Well, if we go back to the chart for a
second, at the beginning of April, we
would have had the March number reported.
And of course, we wouldn't have had the
April number reported because that's
reported in the first week of May.
So we'd be sitting here looking at a very,
very high level on the ISM.
So there's 64.7. And we would probably
start to get very concerned that the ISM
can go no higher from that point.
So we'd probably be thinking to ourselves
at that stage, we are nearing an
inflection point.
And the only way is down.
And then in the first week of May, we are
getting our April number.
And then that moves down very sharply.
So we get our confirmed turning point
leading to a possible trend.
So when you're going through this data,
looking at it visually and then analyzing
it in the tables,
you obviously have to make inferences here
as something that you'll get used to over
time with experience and connecting it to
particular sectors.
But let's stay on the aggregate data for a
second on the component data.
And let's have a look at the direction and
rate of change that's denoted in the month
of April,
which is reported in the first week of
May.
So at the aggregate level, we have our
number of 60.7 dropping from in March
64.7.
So we're down four points and the
direction.
Yes, we're still in a condition of growth.
You know, that's because we're above 50.
The ISM is above 50.
So we're growing.
But the rate of change is slower.
And the trend in months for growth is 11
months for the contributory component
data.
So new orders, production, employment.
We have the same conditions contribute
contributing to the aggregate number.
But it's the same conditions as the
aggregate number.
We see deliveries slowing down.
So the direction is slowing and the rate
of change is slowing down at a slower
pace.
And inventories, this is where we're
seeing a real change here because we get a
change in direction for the first month.
So the direction is now contracting.
So our inventories number is 46.5 dropping
from 50.8.
So contracting and the rate of change from
growing.
So the manufacturing sector is denoted as
growing and growing at a slower pace with
a slower pace with a slower pace.
And the overall economy is denoted the
same growing but at a slower pace with an
11-month trend.
So what we're seeing here is peak
conditions potentially.
And we're seeing some cracks appearing
especially in the drawdown with
inventories which are now contracting.
So remember these numbers for March, they
will have been reported at the beginning
of April.
And the April numbers will have been
reported in May.
So on the first business day of each of
those months.
So over time what you're going to be doing
every month is going through these steps.
And just inferring what is actually
happening in the ISM manufacturing PMI and
the component parts.
And inferring along with all of your other
macro data a portfolio bias.
But when you're actually using leading
indicators like the ISM manufacturing
data, you're going to be looking at the
sector data.
So essentially what we're doing is we're
looking at the sector data with a backdrop
of macroeconomic trend.
So for this example, we are sitting in the
month of April.
And we're assuming that we've just seen
the March data come out for the ISM
manufacturing number.
And we're going to be looking at furniture
and related products as a sector.
And we're looking at transportation
equipment.
So if you recall how we actually organize
this data.
If you recall from the video on the ISM
manufacturing, which is video seven, we
organize the sector data by ranking the 18
sectors by the sector that's growing the
most to the sector that's either growing
the least or contracting.
Or contracting.
And we do this by the most recent month.
So here for an academic exercise, we've
organized it in April 21.
So the data for April that's reported in
the first week of May.
And we've ranked from 18.
So that's electrical equipment, appliances
and components all the way down to the
bottom, which is number one.
So growing the least, which is wood
products.
Now, if we were sitting in the first week
of April, this is something you would do
with the March data.
So you would rank in the same way that
we've done here for April data.
You would rank from highest to lowest in
descending order of growth.
And yes, if we were sitting in the first
week of April looking at this March data,
organizing the data by most growth to
least growth, we'd probably start looking
at the sectors that are growing the most
and growing the least.
So the ones that are the extremities.
So for example, in this table, looking at
the March data, we'd probably be looking
at textile mills, which comes in at 17,
electrical equipment, appliances and
components, which comes in at 16.
And also looking at machinery in the other
extreme.
So growing the least or not growing at
all, or even contracting, we'd probably be
looking at wood products, which comes in
at zero because it's a neutral direction.
We'd also be looking at petroleum and coal
products, which comes in as the lowest
growth at ranked number one on a relative
basis.
And we'd also probably looking at
printing, which comes in with a ranking of
two.
But for the purposes of this example, what
we're going to be looking at here are the
two sectors, furniture and related
products, so potentially looking at long
ideas in that sector and looking at
transportation equipment.
So potentially looking at short ideas, so
potentially looking at short ideas.
And you can see the rankings in the March
data.
So remember, March data reported first
week of April.
Furniture and related products comes in at
a level of 12 in terms of relative ranking
for growth relative to other sectors.
And the transportation equipment comes in
at six.
So if we were ranking these in March, if
we were sitting in the first week of
April, furniture and related products at
12, transportation equipment at six.
They're not in the extremities, but
furniture and related products would be
towards the higher end of growth,
transportation equipment at the lower end
of growth.
What we're also looking at as well is the
trend over the last six months.
So if we look at furniture and related
products going back to November 2020 up
until the March 21 data, what we see is
relatively low growth in November 20 at a
two ranking, jumping in December to a 15
ranking, then back down in January and
February to relatively low levels scoring
or ranking four and two.
And then a big jump in March.
Interpreting this data, this is kind of
what you would expect due to seasonality.
With transportation equipment going back
to November 20 and looking at the six
month trends, we have a growth in November
20 coming in at a three ranking.
It jumps on a relative basis quite big in
December 20 to a 10 ranking.
And then we have that again in January 20
in January 21.
We have a nine ranking, so not much move
there in February 21 and then a drop in
March 21.
So, yes, hindsight is a wonderful thing
and we can look at the data and we can
say, OK, well, if we were sitting in the
first week of May, how will have this
worked out?
Well, on the six month trend, we got
continued growth in furniture and related
products and we got a continued growth but
slowdown of growth for transportation
equipment in April 21.
But of course, we don't have the benefit
of that hindsight of the whole six month
trend when we're sitting in the first week
of April and getting the March 21 data.
What we're looking for here is some sort
of pattern recognition for longs and
shorts in the data.
And what we're really looking for is
divergence.
So divergence on a relative basis.
And if we look at the change in furniture
and related products from the Feb data to
the March data, we see a jump, positive
jump of 10 points.
And then for transportation equipment, we
see a negative move.
So we see this ranking going down in Feb
21 from nine to six in March 21.
So there's definitely divergence occurring
there.
So this would actually get our interest if
we're looking at this data correctly.
If you're interested and seeing potential
longs in the furniture and related
products sector and potential shorts in
the transportation equipment sector.
And of course, if you marry up ideas, long
furniture and short transportation
equipment, by default, what you're
actually doing is you're creating a cross
sector spread trade.
We're looking at more work at the sector
level to figure out where this divergence
is actually coming from.
And here we've got new orders.
So if we look at new orders in furniture
and related products, we imagine ourselves
again sitting in the first week of April.
The data's out, we're doing our work,
looking for potential trade ideas.
We're now looking for divergence at the
new orders level.
If we look at furniture and related
products, we're going from zero neutral in
February 21 to a ranking of 10 on relative
growth in March 21.
And then with transportation equipment,
we're seeing a ranking of eight on
relative growth for the month of February
21.
And then dropping four points or four
rankings in March 21.
So dropping to a ranking of four.
If we look at the next one where we're
getting divergence, this is occurring in
inventories.
So if we look at furniture and related
products first, over those five months,
November 20 to March 21, we're getting
contraction November 20, contraction
December 20, then a big jump in Jan 21.
So a big inventory build on a relative
basis.
So a ranking of nine coming from minus
five in December 20.
Then in Feb 21, we're getting a zero
ranking with neutral.
And then we're jumping to a ranking of
four in terms of growth for March 21.
So this is interesting for inventories
coming from the furniture and related
product sector, because what we're seeing
over that five month trend is an
aggressive drawdown in inventories running
into the holiday period.
Then as soon as we get into the new year,
a big inventory build and then a slowdown
of inventories.
But in terms of interpretation, what we're
probably seeing here from the sector is an
inventory build in expectation of growth
conditions coming in April.
And the build in January in Jan, that
inventory is being used to satisfy the
demand in future months.
Now, of course, in order for us to locate
some divergence here, we have to look at
what's happening in transportation
equipment.
So in November 20, we've got a zero
ranking of neutral December 20 growth
ranking of one.
And then in Jan 21, we're neutral again at
a zero ranking.
The same happening in Feb 21.
And then we get what looks like a fairly
aggressive negative move to the downside.
We get a ranking of negative three with a
direction of contraction.
So if we think about this in terms of
divergence, furniture and related
products, Feb to March, zero to four.
Transportation equipment, neutral for two
months.
So January 21, February 21.
Lowest of growth in December 20.
Neutral in November 20.
And then going negative contraction,
negative three in March 21.
So even just on a one month basis, there's
divergence there when comparing the two
sectors.
But there's also quite a bit of divergence
occurring if we just look at the first
quarter of the year.
So Jan 21 to March 21.
So what would happen here, you'd recognize
that divergence is occurring between two
different sectors.
And then you'd move to the next stage.
So we would start looking at the sectors
themselves.
And we're going to start here with the
transportation equipment sector.
And we're going to look at the
quantitative data for the sector and apply
our quantitative processing steps that
we've been through earlier in the video
series.
So what do we have here?
We are looking first at the short or
potentials as implied by the ISM numbers.
We're looking at the transportation
equipment sector.
And we're looking at all of the
quantitative.
So what's our first step?
Well, as you've seen in previous parts of
the PTM video series, our first step is
always to clean up our spreadsheets.
We want to clean up the data.
And here the data has been cleaned as of
March 1st, 2021 and had a minimum $30
billion filter for market capitalization
applied to the sector because we are
looking at potentially shorting stocks
here.
So if you look at the table, you'll see
some of our quantitative numbers, the
cells have been overwritten following our
data cleaning exercises.
And we've arrived at sector averages for
our quantitative.
So for earnings growth in 2021, so EG1, we
have 46.83% earnings growth in 21 versus
2020.
Earnings growth two, which is our 2022
EPS.
So 22 versus 21 comes in at 38.87%.
We have an average price earnings ratio
for the current year forward looking 2021.
So PE1 of 29.26.
And for the next financial year, so EG2,
which is 2022, our PE is 24.44.
We have a current forward looking PEG.
So current year forward, PEG1 of 1.63.
And then a PEG2 2022 next financial year,
1.21.
Now what we've done here is we've ranked
from top to bottom by market cap.
And through some discretionary work, we
are zooming in and focusing on companies
in the sector that are purer plays.
So those that don't have highly
diversified revenue and earnings in the
sector.
So we arrive at looking at TDG, Transdine
Group, and PACAR, PCAR, not just because
their earnings growth profiles and
valuations relative to the sector average
might be interesting to us from a short
perspective, but also because of the
revenue and earnings mix of the companies
relative to other stocks in the sector.
Why?
Because we want the purest plays possible
in the sector with the most potential
downside.
So TGG and PACAR are purer plays versus
other stocks because they're not as
diversified in their revenues and
earnings.
Also both fit the market cap short
minimum.
So if you recall, when it comes to market
cap, we're roughly looking at $20 billion
plus.
So here we put a minimum of $30 billion to
isolate everything in the sector, every
stock in the sector that has over a $30
billion market cap.
Now the quantitative is how you identify
potential plays, but you do also have to
use some discretion and learn about the
stocks as you're going along.
So here we have to look at that.
So we have to look at that.
And both TDG and PACAR have differing
earnings growth profiles.
They are classed as being in the same
sector, transportation equipment.
However, they are in different businesses
within the same sector.
So TDG is specifically in aircraft
components and PACAR is in trucks and
parts.
Now, why would TGG and PACAR be
interesting to us?
Well, relative to the sector average, TDG
is a turnaround or value trap potential
and PACAR has slightly better than average
earnings growth one and lower than average
earnings growth two.
And also on a forward looking valuation,
TDG trades as a premium to the sector and
PACAR trades at a discount and both have
pegs that are below one and below the
sector average peg.
So these quantitative profiles combined
with their revenue and earnings mix
relative to the sector is interesting to
us from a short perspective.
So if you think about the messages that
the ISM sector data, what the respondents
are saying on a sector basis.
I remember the measurements of sectors
relative to other sectors.
If we think about that backdrop and
deterioration basis in equipment,
obviously we want to be short either the
worst or very close to being the worst
stocks in the sector.
And this feeds these conditions from the
ISM after a lag feed into revenue and
earnings.
And we are attempting to marry up the
macro and the micro and the micro involves
finding what we believe to be stocks that
will get hurt the most.
In this example with a short in
transportation equipment stocks that will
get hurt the most in the sector relative
to others if the backdrop of the sector
continues to deteriorate.
So the quantitative of TDG and PACAR is
interesting to us.
We identify these situations and of course
we then do further work.
Now when it comes to divergence, we of
course look on the other side and we long
long sectors coming from the implied moves
in the sector data on a relative basis
from the ISM.
So we're going to be looking now at
furniture and home furnishing stores.
So again, the data has been cleaned as of
March 1st 21.
And in this instance, no market cap
minimum or maximum has been applied.
Now when it comes to our long discipline
in the table, you can look at the market
caps.
We're going to look at the market cap.
We have to look at the market cap.
Of course, in real life, when you're going
through this, you would probably be doing
work on all three of these stocks and
determining what the real situation is.
Now, at home group, home is a similar
earnings growth profile to TDG, even
though they're in totally different
sectors.
So they can both be classified as
potential turnarounds or value traps.
However, when you think about the macro
backdrop, the sector data from ISM, what
respondents in the survey are reporting at
this moment in time, according to that
data, TDG has a sector headwind and home
has a sector tailwind.
And also in the transportation equipment
sector, PACCAR also has a sector headwind
as implied by the macro data with some of
the lowest PE multiples.
So forward looking valuation in the
sector.
So if we were running through this as a
case study in hindsight, we can look at
how this type of trade performed over our
time horizon.
So let's look at our long first at home
group.
What do they actually do?
Well, they own and operate home decor
stores, very straightforward operation.
So they're selling furniture, home
furnishings, wall decor, decorative
accents, rugs and housewares, etc.
And predominantly in the United States.
Let's have a look on the chart what this
stock actually did after ISM numbers came
out.
So you can see here in the first week of
April, this is where the March ISM numbers
were reported.
And you can see at the beginning of May,
this is where the April ISM number was
reported.
So that survey data that we looked at, the
sector data from the ISM survey, these are
the points at which those numbers were
reported.
So the relative sector numbers where we
spotted divergence.
So if we just think of the performance
here of the stock home in the month of
April, for example.
So after or the moment that the March ISM
data was released up until the moment
where the April ISM data was released at
the beginning of May.
So we think about the April performance of
this stock price.
The stock is basically going from $26 to
around $33.
So a $7 performance of a starting number
starting base of around 26, which gives us
about a 27% return in one month.
Now what's interesting about this case
study is that the jump that you see in the
stock price, where it's going from around
$33 at the beginning of May and jumping up
to $36.
So that gap, the move up there, that was
because the company was bid for and a
takeover announcement occurred from a
private equity company called Hellman and
Friedman.
So why this case study is so interesting
and so good is because if we were going
through our processes at the time, looking
through the ISM, trying to get macro
implied single stock trades from our ISM
sector analysis.
If we were going through those processes,
going through those processes, you would
have probably looked at something like
home group in your analysis.
So your timing would have been pretty
amazing.
So you're sitting at the beginning of
April 2021 and you're looking at the March
ISM data coming out and looking at
divergence in the sector data.
Then looking at the micro work as well and
going through the quantitative and going
through those processes, you will have
drilled down and zoomed in potentially on
home group and got exposure to that.
And these things sometimes happen.
Why?
Because the processes that we're going
through are the same processes that smart
money are going through in the market at
the same time.
And they will have been doing the same
analysis and coming to the same
conclusions as us.
If we're going through the whole process,
identifying the stock using the
quantitative identifying what type of
trade it is.
And then on top of that, doing all of the
extra work in the process, they will have
come to the same or very similar
conclusions.
That home group is a turnaround story with
merit from a bottom up perspective with
macro and sector tailwinds.
And what ends up happening about five
weeks, six weeks after we identify it,
private equity bid for the stock and take
it private.
Now, we're not saying this happens all the
time, obviously, but we've used this as an
example because it does happen.
We are doing the same analysis as the
smart money in the market.
Why?
Because our processes are the processes of
smart money.
In the majority of cases, if you have all
of your ducks lined up in a row, all the
boxes are ticked and everything in the
process is giving you a green light.
In the majority of situations, you're
going to get a nice organic move that you
can capture in the stock price within the
20 to 60 day time horizon.
But sometimes you do get a bit lucky in
your time horizon.
In the minority of cases, you do get lucky
sometimes.
And sometimes there's an announcement like
this, like a takeover.
Now, what about the case study here?
Well, let's start with TDG.
Remember, these guys were very
concentrated relative to other stocks in
the sector in terms of their revenue and
earnings.
And these guys were in the aircraft
components manufacturing business.
So if we look at the chart of TDG, we can
again look at the performance of the
stock.
If we traded short at the beginning of
April when we got the March ISM data and
the beginning of May when we got the April
ISM data.
So you can see here with TDG, if we think
about April performance here, the stock's
moving roughly from a level of $590 up to
about $620.
So that's a $30 move of a $590 base.
But then the stock drops back to around
$595, $600 in the last week of April.
But it does end the month around $610.
So over that month of April, the stock
does go up to a high of around $620, $630.
So you're looking at a $30, $40 move on
the stock from the $590 level.
So we're looking at a peak performance in
the month of April of around between 5%
and almost 7% before the stock goes back
down again to be around flat on the month
or just a little bit better than that in
the last week of April.
And then ends the month at around $610,
which is a $20 increase of $590 at the
beginning of the month.
So you're basically looking at a 3, 3.5%
monthly performance after the March ISM is
repeated.
Look at this performance in the same time
period on a chart relative to a home group
and look at it indexed to 100.
But here we're going back one month more
and indexing to 100 from the beginning of
March.
And that's just to display really when the
big divergence started occurring.
So we can see this in the total picture.
I'm both before the takeover announcement
for home group was out publicly in the
market and after the takeover announcement
was out there.
Home group was outperforming TDG by a very
good margin both before and after that
announcement.
So if we look at total performance here
after the takeover announcement, you're
looking at home group up 34.89% after the
April ISM was reported and after the
takeover announcement.
And that's in comparison to TDG.
And over that time period, the whole time
period, we're looking at a 75 basis point
or let's say 1% move in the stock, which
essentially means it didn't really move.
It's flat.
But even before the April ISM is reported
at the beginning of May, we can see that
there's divergence.
And we can see, for example, in the last
few trading days of April, we can see that
home group is up around 25% versus TDG,
which is again essentially flat.
So divergence is occurring in the stock
prices after the March ISM is reported and
continues after the April ISM is reported.
After the April ISM is reported, that's
mainly down to the takeover.
But what's interesting as well is that
there was actually some divergence in the
month of March.
So imagine we were sitting there at the
beginning of April and we were looking at
our sector data from the ISM.
We were looking at home furnishings,
stocks, furniture stocks, and doing the
quantitative qualitative assessment on a
few of them.
We may have even started looking at
technical indicators and price action as
well in terms of timing.
And divergence from stocks like home group
versus its own sector versus other stocks
across the market versus other sectors as
well may have actually indicated a good
time for us to go in to stocks like home
group.
Because we were getting indications of
divergence in the near past, so in terms
of price action.
Now, what about our other short PACAR,
E-C-A-R?
If you remember, this was also selected in
the quantitative as also having more
concentrated revenue and earnings relative
to the sector.
But also as having inferior quantitative
relative to sector averages, especially
when it came to valuation.
So in terms of valuation on a discount to
the sector and identifying this stock as a
potential negative outlier.
So what do these guys do?
Well, they design, develop, manufacture
and distribute light, medium and heavy
duty trucks and the aftermarket
distribution of parts.
If we look at this stock at the time in
absolute terms, like we did with TDG
first, what are we looking at here?
Well, actually, in the month of April,
after the March ISM was reported, this
stock over the month actually went down.
So we're looking at a stock price over the
month of April that went from around
$92.50 down to 90.
So we're looking at an almost negative 3%
move down for the stock in the month of
April.
And then after the April ISM data is
released at the beginning of May, the
stock rallied that week quite quickly to
above 95.
So we can see here, no surprises, if we
look at this relative to home group, we
get a similar spread performance over the
entire period as we do when we look at
home group versus TDG.
Essentially, the stocks that we identified
as negative outliers in the transportation
equipment sector, so per car and TDG, they
were both flat or up tiny over the whole
period.
However, per car in the month of April
itself performed worse than TDG.
And this type of stock price performance
over this period, so the month of April
after the ISM data for March is released,
this type of stock price performance does
speak to the valuation of the discount for
forward looking PE.
When we were doing our quantitative
processing and identifying potential
negative outliers.
If you recall, per car was on a quite a
big discount to the sector.
Whereas T in terms of forward looking PE
was actually on a premium to the sector
average.
So it's very likely that if we were
sticking to our guns, sticking to our
processes here in the quantitative, it's
more than likely that we would have chosen
per car as our short.
So you can see here, over our 20 to 60 day
time horizons, you can process very
efficiently, very optimally, and infer
potential trade ideas in single stocks
when you're marrying up both the macro and
the micro.
And what we looked at here in this video
in terms of the case studies happens time
and time again in US equity markets.
Because we are actually implementing
professional trader processes and even
professional investor processes, we are
doing the same work as institutional
money.
The same work as institutional traders and
investors.
They are looking at the same things that
you are looking at.
They are spotting the same macro and micro
trends.
And many of them will be generating the
same or very similar ideas in single stock
equities.
So you can get light bulb indications or
clues of where to look in the stock market
from the ISM surveys in order to generate
trade ideas.
What have you got to do?
You've got to go through a monthly
quantitative and qualitative process of
organizing all the numbers and the
statements and look for those trends and
turning points in the aggregate data and
also at the sector level.
And of course, you've got to get the right
sectors and the right stocks within those
sectors as identified by your processes,
by your best practices.
So by your sector quant analysis.
On top of that, you obviously have to
still go through the qualitative work.
And all of the other processes that we're
going through in the video series to
identify potential stocks that are going
to move from the indicated trends and
divergence in the ISM.
So when you're using the ISM, use it as a
place to get clues as to what might be
happening in certain sectors, then go
through the rest of your processes that
are required to actually generate what we
define as a trade idea.
Do not jump the gun, no shortcuts, please.
And do not look at a number in the ISM, so
the sector data, then look for any stock
in the sector without doing further work.
Then think it's a trade idea and put a
position on.
You've got to do a lot more work than
that.
And additionally, and as a reminder, we
said this earlier in the video series.
Do not rely on the ISM as your only place
that you look for potential trade ideas.
Now, when it came to our example that we
used here, of course, we would at the time
also be looking at other sectors in the
ISM that exhibited trend changes or
continuations of strong trend.
And I can tell you now at the time, and
this will be the same every month.
There were other sectors from the March
and April ISM data and the six months
sector data where we could have gotten
very strong potential ideas from.
The beauty of this example that we used,
the processing example that we used, is
that it's very simple to understand and
it's very easy to replicate.
It can be repeated on a step by step
basis, not just for ISM manufacturing data
going forward, but also non manufacturing
data.
It's very easy to implement.
It's very easy to implement the ISM
services numbers.
And always remember, guys, the ISM doesn't
tell you exactly what to do.
It's not a plug and play rule book.
What we're doing here is we're organizing
quantitative data to look for potential
opportunities via our process of
identification and using clues that we
pick up from the ISM data.
The process that we're going through here,
where we're marrying up the macro and the
micro, it's an identification process.
Again, this is the same as the discovery
or identification phase when we're looking
at only the micro level and we're doing
quant processing at the sector level after
we've already established a portfolio bias
from the aggregate macro data.
And then when we go straight into sectors
to look for positive and negative
outliers.
So when we're marrying up macro and micro
and we're looking at organizing ISM
manufacturing or services data at the
sector level and trying to look at trends
and divergence.
We're essentially going through a similar
identification process as when we do at
the micro level for our quantitative
processing.
So it's sector trend sector divergence
identification from ISM data and then
quantitative processing identification of
positive and negative outliers at the
quantitative level and then marrying the
two up.
And yes, it can take a bit of practice and
experience to get used to this.
But you can see from our case study in the
video, which is very typical of things
that go on in financial markets after
macro data is released in single equities.
You can see from our example that the
returns are worth the work.
And it's worth mentioning here again.
Do not forget the four principles of ITPM.
And do not forget that you absolutely have
to be a self starter to get consistency.
No one is going to do the work for you.
You have to do the work here.
You've got to be self sustainable, have a
strong work ethic, get the free
information like we've seen here today and
work smart and not hard.
As a reminder from earlier in the video
series with the ISM data, valuable
information can be gleaned from it on a
monthly basis.
If you do have the self starter mentality
and you actually do the work yourself.
You've got to do your own work, generate
your own trade ideas and make your own
returns.
There's no spoon feeding or copy trading
at the professional level.
You have to process alone and efficiently
to establish a portfolio bias, identify
positive and negative outliers and
everything in between for your chosen
sector.
And do the extra work for the backwards
looking quant and the forward looking
qualitative information to support your
quant identification process.
And in addition, again, process alone and
efficiently to generate potential trade
ideas that are inferred from ISM data,
both at the aggregate level and what we've
looked at today, the sector data at the
sector level for trends and divergence.
Be organized, maintain folders for your
ideas by distilling down to the most
important information for each potential
idea utilizing our trade idea template.
As a trader portfolio manager, your trade
ideas are your inventory.
An inventory is the oxygen to your long
short portfolio.
Small amounts of low quality ideas make
profitable long short portfolio management
absolutely impossible.
You constantly need an abundance of high
quality, fresh and current trade ideas to
feed your long short portfolio.
Work on your way, find the time to do it
and on a weekly basis, you're aiming to
generate two new fresh ideas per week to
support your already healthy trade idea
inventory.
You need to do this work on a regular
basis of the self-starter mentality to get
consistency and to get to the top of the
competency hierarchy to the professional
level.
Okay, so guys that brings us to the end of
this video.
So we're done here with our examples and
case studies of how to marry up the macro
and micro analysis in order to generate
trade ideas.
Let's move straight into the next video
where we're going to be looking at
generating international trade ideas via
ADRs.
Let's move straight into the next video.